[Musique]
aux dsi mortels écoute donc m'avoir toi
qui tiens en tutelle
mon pouvoir sous des lois afin que si ma
vie se voit en bref ravi tu as cru hôtel
à confesse péri par sa seule beauté est
néanmoins la flamme qui me brûle en en
flammes de passion née mais jamais ton
âme d'aucune infection
ainsi parlait l'infortuné gentilhomme
poète chaste l'art consumé par la vive
et dangereuse passion que lui inspire la
reine mary stuart au point de se cacher
dans la chambre de la belle ce qui lui
vaut d'être condamné à mort et décapité
reine decosse à six jours
en 15 942 d'abord promise au fils du roi
d'angleterre
marie stuart arrive à la cour de france
à 6 ans où elle est élevée avec le
dauphin françois fils d'henri de marie
stuart qu est une très belle femme mais
parce qu'elle faisait un mètre 75
qu'elle avait des des yeux éblouis sens
qu'elle était et est vive elle était
joyeuse et bien devient reine de france
en épousant le pl et françois deux à
l'aube des guerres de religion et
factions catholiques et protestantes
s'affrontent déjà pour le pouvoir
oumar histoire c'est tout un symbole
avec un père roy décosse est une mère
française
elle incarne cette longue tradition
d'alliance entre la france et les cosses
contre leurs ennemis séculaires
l'angleterre
par sa grand mère marguerite tudor marie
stuart est une héritière présomptif du
trône d'angleterre le royaume devenu
anglicans par la volonté d'henri 8 fait
alors l'objet d'une farouche guerre de
succession avant que la couronne ne soit
finalement déposé sur la tête
d'elisabeth première la mort du roi de
france françois 215 160 ramène marie
stuart en écosse royaume également en
proie aux dissensions religieuses
après deux mariages imprudent un
assassinat et une gouvernance malhabile
elle devient une souveraine décriait
contraintes d'abdiquer en faveur de son
fils elle est emprisonnée avant de
s'enfuir en angleterre où elle va
demeurer captive pendant 18 ans accusé
de comploter contre elisabeth 1ère le
destin tragique de marie stuart l'a
conduit sur l'échafaud le 8 février 15
187 et va inspirer pour des siècles des
générations entières d'écrivains
laissant place à la légende de
l'intrigante et de la reine martyrs
victimes du protestantisme
m
on
marie stuart voit le jour le 8 décembre
15 942 au palais de l'isg aux résidences
royales des souverains décosse arrière
petite fille du roi henri 7 d'angleterre
et les filles du roi jacques cinq
membres de la prestigieuse dynastie des
stuart qui règne sur l'ecosse depuis
treize 171 et à partir du xviie siècle
sur l'angleterre l'irlande et le pays de
galles par sa mère mary 2 ghz
elle est également issu de la puissante
maison souveraine de lorraine l'ecosse
est un royaume indépendant qui résiste
depuis des siècles aux assauts répétés
de son voisin angle jacques 5 décosse
est le neveu du roi henri 8 qui règne
sur l'angleterre depuis quinze 109
épouse de ce dernier
catherine d'aragon ne lui a donné qu'une
fille marie tudor et le roi s'inquiètent
de la pérennité de son trône de plus il
est tombé éperdument amoureux de sa
sulfureuse maîtresse anne boleyn qui lui
promet de lui donner un fils pour
pouvoir l'épouser en ruine demande alors
au pape clément 7 l'annulation de son
premier mariage
devant le refus du souverain pontife
l'impétueux monarque fondé l'église
anglicane et provoque un schisme
religieux l'angleterre devient alors
protestante bouleversant les rapports de
force sur le théâtre européen
naturellement henry 8 demande à son
neveu écossais de rompre lui aussi avec
l'église catholique romaine
mais jacques 5 fait mine d'ignorer sa
requête ne s'ouvre à anglet entre dans
une colère noire et fait marcher ses
troupes contre l'unfp selon roy décosse
les armées rivales s'affrontent à sal où
est mort le 24 novembre 15 140 de la
victoire est décisive pour le camp
anglais et jacques 5 épuisé par la
maladie rend l'âme le 14 décembre 15 942
à la mort de son père
marie stuart est propulsée reine decosse
à seulement six jours sous le nom de
marie première suscitant les convoitises
de la france comme celle de son ennemi
juré
l'angleterre la france décosse bénéficie
en effet d'une longue tradition
d'entr'aide entérinée par l'ong alliance
en 12 195 un traité de protection
mutuelle contre l'angleterre marc
histoire n'a que quelques jours à la
mort de son père le roi jacques 5
il s'agit de désigner un régent pour
gouverner le royaume jusqu'à sa majorité
car la loi salique n'existe pas en
écosse et marie une fois majeur sera la
reine en titre
le cardinal et chancelier david beaton
produit un testament qui le désigne
parmi les régents potentiel du royaume
or le plus proche héritier de la
couronne le comte daran james hamilton
conteste ce testament il est déclaré fu
devant le parlement
il obtient la régence est fait
prisonnier betten le régent se montre
alors favorable à l'union anglaise la
promesse de mariage entre marie stuart
et le futur edouard cisse d'angleterre
est donc scellé par le traité de
greenwich le 1er juillet 15 143
pourtant afin de garantir l'indépendance
du royaume
le parlement écossais fait volte face
décide de se rapprocher de la france
héron la promesse faite au roi
d'angleterre furieux en réduite entame
une politique guerrière connu sous le
nom de l'ofs wing le compte de hartford
edward seymour mais alors les cosses à
feu et à sang
les écossais résiste et le 27 février 15
145 ils sont victorieux à la bataille
d'encre mort à la mort d'henri 8 en 15
147 son fils edouard cisse accède au
trône d'angleterre
comme il est mineur le gouvernement du
royaume revient
l'homme protecteur et doivent seymour
celui ci poursuit la politique guerrière
à l'encontre de l'ecosse devant la
violence des incursions anglaise mary 2
ghz place sa fille sous la protection de
la france est la promesse au dauphin
françois fils aîné d'henri ii et
catherine de médicis en juillet 15 148
marie stuart est alors envoyée à la cour
de france pour y être élevée avec son
futur époux et auprès de ses oncles
fervent catholique françois de guise et
le cardinal charles de lorraine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment
quand elle arrive en france à l'été 15
148 marie stuart découvre sa nouvelle
patrie gouverné par levallois henry 2
marie à la florentine catherine de
médicis la maison de valois branche
cadette de la dynastie capétienne règne
sur le royaume depuis l'avènement de
philippe six ans 13 128
il ouvre la voie aux valois le plus
célèbre de l'histoire
françois 1er
le fils de ce dernier henry 2 hérite
d'une france forte mais au coeur d'un
duel avec l'autre puissance catholique
européenne la maison de habsbourg dirigé
par l'empereur charles quint
les territoires habsburg encerclent le
royaume de france et depuis la fin du
xvème siècle les monarques des deux
camps s'affrontent dans les guerres
d'italie pour imposer leur suprématie
[Musique]
ce devait elle naît à la fin du xvème
siècle à partir du moment où la france
commence à prendre une autorité en
europe après la guerre de cent ans après
s'être construit à l'intérieur du
royaume et elle google commence
justement à développer l'idée de une
idée dans pire qu'elle pourrait
construire à partir de la péninsule
italienne
et ce duel vagues ont commencé à partir
de maximilien à l'époque et maximilien
et cher le 8 et louis xii après avoir
mené 9 guerre en italie entre 14 294 et
15 144 une trêve s'installe mais le
royaume est aussi en proie à des
dissensions religieuses auxquelles henry
2 doit faire face la réforme protestante
a gagné du terrain depuis la critique du
commerce des indulgences par martin
luther dans ses 95 thèses placardée sur
la porte de l'église de wittenberg en 15
117 le réformateur prône un retour aux
sources du christianisme en attaquant
ses papes devenus des princes qui se
fourvoie dans le luxe
dans les années 15,150 jean calvin
organise cette conquête des âmes et
fédère les protestants français la
réforme séduit de plus en plus d'adeptes
et henry 2 ne parvient pas à instaurer
l'unité religieuse du royaume
soul influence de sa favorite la très
catholique diane de poitiers le roi mène
alors une politique répressive à l'égard
de ceux qu'on appelle les huguenots la
période nouri 2 c'est le début des
guerres de religion
exactement et en rideau n'est pas très
partisan de la cause huguenote tout
protestante
en cela il est extrêmement influencé par
diane de poitiers qui a été élevé dans
le catholicisme pur et dur et qui lui
dit henry a lui dit il ne faut pas que
les mots est une influence considérable
on va d'ailleurs à cause des loups ou
grâce à elle dirait disaient les
catholiques de cette époque-là signe les
10 des coûts ans qui interdisait le
culte protestant sur le royaume de
france
dans ce climat religieux extrêmement
fragile marie stuart grandi aux côtés de
son futur époux
le jeune françois et se lie d'amitié
avec la soeur de ce dernier
elisabeth de valois les deux princesses
reçoivent une éducation humaniste et
entretiennent une abondante
correspondance sa grand mère antoinette
de bourgon et ses oncles françois de
guise et le cardinal de lorraine veille
à ce qu'elle reçoive une bonne éducation
catholique comme marie et la future
reine de france dans son entourage on
joue des coudes pour se placer au mieux
auprès d'elle l'église est en lorrain
d'ailleurs souvent les surnomme les
lorrains ne sont pas français il ya une
partie de la lorraine qui dépend de la
france et à la partie la plus importante
qui fait partie de l' empire et qui est
donc une principauté indépendante donc
ayant un pied en france et un pied à
l'extérieur de france ils ont la
possibilité de jouer un rôle extrêmement
important
la beauté et l'érudition de la jeune
reine decosse fascine les poètes de la
cour tél joachim du bellay mon corps
brantôme en bon courtisan brantôme ne
tarit pas d'éloges sur la jeune reine
decosse et l'a décrite ainsi venant sur
les quinze ans sa beauté commencent à
apparaître comme la lumière en plein
midi et en effacer le soleil lorsqu'il
luizet le plus fort elle avait encore
cette perfection pour embraser le monde
la voix très douce et très bonne
[Musique]
pendant ce temps sur le théâtre européen
un nouvel équilibre semble se mettre en
place
après la mort du jeune roi d'angleterre
le protestant edwards 6 ans 15 153 sa
demi soeur marie tudor fille d'henri 8
de catherine d'aragon parvient par la
force à monter sur le trône d'angleterre
la reine entreprend alors de ramener le
royaume dans le giron catholique
l'année suivante la mère de marie stuart
mary 2 ghz devient régente du royaume
nikos mais la situation reste tendue
entre valois et habsbourg et le duel
reprend la voie des armes
charles quint temps d'annexer aux pays
bas espagnols cambrai les principales
villes de lorraine province protégé par
la france henri de riposte aussitôt en
s'emparant de toul metz et verdun le
courte trêve est conclue après
l'abdication de charles quint 25 octobre
15 155 en faveur de son fils philippe ii
d'espagne
mais de 7 juin 15 157 marie tudor reine
d'angleterre et nouvelle épouse de
philippe ii d'espagne déclare la guerre
à la france prenant ainsi part au
conflit les forces espagnoles
envahissent la france depuis les
pays-bas et inflige à henri ii une
sévère défaite à saint quentin le
connétable de montmorency rival déguise
et fait prisonnier francs sur 2 ghz
s'emparent à leur héroïquement de calais
dernière enclave anglaise sur le
territoire français en janvier 15 158
[Musique]
marie tudor mort la même année laissant
le trône d'angleterre vacants
[Musique]
elisabeth revendique alors la couronne
elle est la fille d'henri 8 de sa
seconde épouse anne boleyn pour laquelle
le roi avait rompu avec rome et fondé
l'église anglicane mais la prétendante
est considéré comme illégitime par les
catholiques
car la première union d'henri 8 avec
catherine d'aragon n'a pas été annulée
par le pape la couronne doit donc
revenir à la soeur dans réduite
marguerite tudor dont la descendante
directe n'est autre que mary stuart le
roi de france s'empresse alors de faire
proclamer sa belle-fille reine
d'angleterre d'irlande et décosse mais
l'anglicane elisabeth première accède
finalement au trône d'angleterre le 17
novembre 15 958
pendant ce temps la cour de france
accueille des parlementaires écossais
pour discuter des termes du contrat de
mariage entre marie stuart et le futur
françois deux signé le 19 avril 15 158
il scelle le rapprochement des deux
royaumes tout en conservant leur
indépendance leur administration et
leurs lois respectives
le contrat de mariage entre marc
histoire et le futur françois 2 stipule
que les sujets et que c'est vivant en
france deviennent français et vice et
versa
le 24 avril 15 158 marie stuart épouse
le dauphin françois à notre dame de
paris
françois a reçu le nom de son illustre
grand père
le vainqueur de marignan mais il est de
constitution fragile
le dauphin partage la passion familiale
pour la chasse et selon ce sans
modération dans ce violent substitut de
la guerre mais son état de santé ne lui
permet pas d'égaler son père
ce mariage stratégique permet aux guides
d'affermir leur influence à la cour
alors on sait qu henri deux quais
partisans de du pape et les catholiques
dans l'âme profonde et mangue et surtout
grâce à sa maîtresse diane de poitiers
qu'il l'est plus encore et bien est très
proche des guides qui eux se sont sont
également des catholiques pur et dur et
en faisant épouse et la petite marie et
marie stuart à son fils françois de son
aîné eh bien il introduit l'église à la
cour française puisque marie est la
fille d'une guise précisément alors que
les festivités du mariage s'achève une
paix se dessine en europe
touteleurope pratiquement est en cause
un l'angleterre la hollande
l'espagne et tous ces pays là vont
devoir signer enfin signé les accords de
cateau cambrésis en quoi consistent ces
accords et bien se sont sensiblement des
affaires religieuses parce que henri ii
cèdent toutes les ses prétentions sur
l'italie en demandant à l'espagne de
l'aider et éventuellement contre leno et
avec l'angleterre
eh bien il joue le jeu contraire il dit
à elisabeth la reine d'angleterre est
bien coûter en effet vous avez consacré
le culte anglicans chez vous je ferme
les yeux mais vous me rendais calais il
a récupéré canet
[Musique]
cette paix de 459 est essentiel parce
que elle va permettre à la fois de
mettre un point final à plus de 40 ans
de guerre ce n'est pas rien à recréer
des liens entre l' empire conduit non
plus par charles quint parce qu'il a
abdiqué mais par son fils philippe 2 et
en partie en tout cas et par
l'angleterre qui maintenant est sous la
tutelle de elisabeth 1ère c'est aussi
une période donc où on affirme où la
france va affirmer définitivement son
abandon de l'italie
c'est henry 2 à accepter cette paix qui
paraît pour beaucoup aujourd'hui une
peine malheureuse parce que quand on
imagine qu'il a rendu toutes ses
conquêtes de 120 c'est à dire la corse
une partie du luxembourg une partie des
flandres et la savoie
et puis tous ces droits qu'ils avaient
sur gêne sur milan sur nar justement
c'est ptet va apporter une paix
définitive en tout cas est que ces
personnes lan qui gagnent tant d'argent
en faisant la guerre en italie ou
ailleurs et bien nous n'aurons plus ses
bénéfices et bien aura l'avantagé au
moins d'avoir repris calais et donc
empêcher les anglais de débarquer sur la
france aussi facilement et puis aussi de
garder ces trois évêchés toul verdun et
metz qui étaient des territoires qui
étaient des enclaves à là mais à
l'intérieur du royaume de france et qui
vont en tout cas proche et les proches
du duché de lorraine et qui permettait
aux allemands ou en tout cas au dos aux
impériaux devenir plus rapidement en
france et est ravagé la picardie la
champagne voire même menacé paris
stratégiquement s'était finalement très
très fin mais c'était pas spectaculaire
par rapport à une idée de conquête la
paix de cateau cambrésis met donc fin au
duel valois habsburg anéantissant les
rêves de conquête italienne formulées
par les rois de france depuis la fin du
xvème siècle l'économie française sort
exemples de ces guerres
mais henry 2 espère profiter de la paix
pour purger le royaume de la réforme
protestante qui a gagné du terrain
pour concrétiser la paix avec les
habsbourg et assurer l'équilibré entre
les deux pays
henri ii organise des fêtes somptueuses
pour le mariage de sa fille aînée
elizabeth de valois avec le monarque le
plus puissant d'europe
philippe ii d'espagne elisabeth de
valois est une des filles de 1re et 2e
et va épouser donc après comme tous les
pères se finissent souvent par des
mariages elle va épouser philippe ii
d'espagne est donc lié par le mariage
en plus des traités de paix et d toutes
les contrats qui ont été faits donc lié
spirituellement deux nations qui se sont
fait la guerre pendant 40 ans c'est à
dire la france et l' empire henri ii est
un colosse bel homme rompu à tous les
exercices physiques il tient beaucoup de
françois 1er son père et henry 2 ème
beaucoup l'un des grands sports des gens
de sa catégorie j'allais dire c'est à
dire des rois des princes de la grande
noblesse qu'elle est tournoi se
substitue delà de la guerre au cours des
festivités
un tournoi est organisé au palais des
tournelles le roi henry 2 contre l'avis
de ses ministres et de la reine
catherine participent aux joutes et
rivalisent de prouesses la font alors le
compte de montgomerie capitaine de sa
garde écossaise
et donc à plusieurs reprises il eu cours
à cheval contre les chevaliers qui
s'opposent à lui
et chaque fois ils l'emportent mes deux
adversaires font deux fois le tour de la
lys se rencontrent et se rate à la
troisième rencontre leur lance vole en
éclats un fragment atteindre home du roi
et lui écorche l'oeil
victime d'une infection henri ii
succombe le 10 juillet 15 159
[Musique]
la mort brutale d'henri 2 plonge le
royaume de france dans une situation
d'extrême instabilité qui va conduire à
une véritable crise monarchique et
laisser éclater les guerres de religion
[Musique]
avec catherine de médicis il a tout de
même quatre fils capable de régner hélas
le petit françois il à charles il à
henry et il a encore un petit dernier
qui est recul le duc d'alençon
donc ce serait bien le diable quand même
que parmi ces quatre héritiers n'y en a
pas un qui est un fils susceptibles de
régner un jour ou l'autre la mort de
henry 2 qui a été une mort alors
complètement inattendu était là dans la
force de l'âge et sa disparition va
évidemment créer des troubles très
profond et cette mort va apparaître
comme un signe pour les contemporains du
désaveu de dieu à l'égard de ce qui se
passe en france un des catholiques vont
dire voilà c'est dieu qui n'est pas
content de voir que le protestantisme se
développe
et puis un certain nombre de pasteurs
calviniste qui vont dire voilà c'est
dieu qui punit la france dans la maison
royale à cause des désordres henry 2
laisse une france en faillite est
divisée sur le plan religieux
le fils aîné que lui a donnée catherine
de médicis est âgé de 15 ans seulement
il lui succède
sous le nom de françois ii
[Musique]
le nouveau souverain est couronné à
reims le 21 septembre 15 159 son épouse
écossaise marie stuart est alors
propulsée reine de france
la majorité du roi est remise en
question par les réformes et qui
soutiennent l'idée d'une tutelle et vont
de ce fait à l'encontre de l'ordonance
de charles 5 2 13 174 qui fixe la
majorité royal à 14 ans à la mort de
charles 5 l'ordonance n'a pas été
appliquée charles ciss a été déclarée
majeur alors qu'il n'avait pas 12 ans
laissant à saison que le soin de
gouverner en son nom jusqu'à ses 20 ans
les protestants réclame alors la
convocation des états généraux en
espérant qu ils confieront la direction
du royaume au prince du sang cette
proposition de mise sous tutelle du roi
françois ii qui est pourtant majeur aux
yeux de la loi n'est pas sans arrière
pensée qui sont ces princes du sang
auquel ils veulent confier la direction
des affaires il s'agit du roi consorts
de navarre
mary jane d'albret antoine de bourbon et
de son frère louis de condé
or ils sont tous les deux sympathisants
de la réforme il y a donc là une
tentative des protestants pour affirmer
sinon leur légitimité au moins leur
existence
après le renforcement du pouvoir royal
sous lé règne de françois 1er puis dans
l'es21 jeunesse de françois de réveil
donc la soif de pouvoir des princes
deux familles rivales s'affrontent pour
atteindre les sommets de l'état les
bourbons il aiguise françois 2 c'est une
occasion qui est une occasion je dirais
presque exceptionnel il est de santé
très chétive il succède à son père henri
ii qui n'était pas très maniable et qui
hésitaient beaucoup à commencer des
guerres civiles
même si henri ii qui était très soucieux
de son autorité de roy n'admettait pas
un certain nombre d'attitudes
protestante et françois deux évidemment
ce droit qui a très peu qui est chétif
et donc l'église ont une position
exceptionnelle à ce moment là un restart
convainc son époux de confier le
gouvernement saison plus fervents
catholiques le duc françois de guise et
le cardinal charles de lorraine très
influençable et manquant d'autorité
françois 2 préfère se consacrer à la
chasse et des legs l'exercice du pouvoir
ou guise les grisons une forte emprise
sur françois 2 car l'église sont très
proches de la famille royale mais ne
font pas véritablement partie des
princes du sang or l'église considère
que dans la mesure où ils appartiennent
à une maison souveraine qui est la
maison de lorraine
ils ont autant de titres que les princes
du sang à pouvoir participer au pouvoir
ce pouvoir qui est considéré dans
l'opinion de l'époque comme une sorte de
copropriété des principaux prince
françois de guise prend la direction de
l'armée et poursuit la politique de
répression religieuse conduite par le
défunt roi à l'égard des protestants le
cardinal de lorraine s'emploie quant à
lui à restaurer les finances du royaume
devant les dettes colossales
le cardinal engage des économies
drastiques il abaisse les intérêts des
dettes de l'état licencient les soldats
à jour ne le paiement des soldes
l'église sont très attachés à la
contre-réforme on ne parle pas encore de
contre-réforme à cette époque mais on
est déjà dans des guerres de religion
entre catholiques et protestants
les dix ont décidé de soutenir la cause
catholique sans état d'âme y compris par
la force et en particulier dans les
terres qui dépendent d'eux ils
n'admettent pas qu'il puisse y avoir des
réunions des prêches et ils vont se
signaler par un certain nombre de
massacres adoptant cette attitude sur
leurs terres ils considèrent que de
manière générale ils doivent être
chaque fois que c'est possible chaque
fois que leurs forces le leur permettent
les champions de la cause que de la
cause catholique l'église écarte la
reine-mère des affaires du royaume et
entame une répression féroce contre les
partisans de la réforme
le conseiller au parlement anne du bourg
on est la première victime embastillé
par henry 2 pour avoir défendu les idées
calviniste
malgré la mort du roi et après un
simulacre de procès les condamnés comme
hérétique à être pendue puis brûlé en
place de grève le 23 décembre 15 au 159
mais les mesures prises par les qu'ils
éveillent bientôt le ressentiment des
princes
s'il était difficile de critiquer la
répression à l'égard des protestants
soit henry 2 évidemment il n'en est pas
de même pour l'église on conteste seront
qualifiés en majorité les protestants la
légitimité de ces lorrains considérés
comme des étrangers qui manipule le roi
pour mettre l'église en accusation ces
nobles mécontents ont besoin du soutien
du premier prince du sang antoine de
bourbon habilité à convoquer les états
généraux pour trancher la question de la
légitimité du pouvoir
le réformateur calvin on fait d'ailleurs
une condition préalable à son soutien or
antoine de bourbon a bien autre chose en
tête son royaume de navarre a été en
partie conquis par les espagnols
l'église qui ont de bonnes relations
avec l'espagne catholique pourrait
intervenir en sa faveur
il choisit donc de se dérober de même
que son frère le prince de condé
la soumission des bourbons à la famille
de guise est un mauvais coup porté à la
cause protestante l'hostilité des nobles
grandi au point qu'ils vont décider
d'agir seul sans le soutien des chefs
religieux protestants ou même des grands
du royaume
c'est ce que l'on va appeler la
conjuration d'amboise c'est gentilhomme
provinciaux se réunissent donc derrière
jean du baril seigneur de la renaudie
avec la ferme intention de délivrer le
roi de la tutelle d'église le 1er
février 15 160 les conjurés se
réunissent à nantes
dès le 12 février le complot est éventé
il aiguise y voit d'abord la main des
anglais de 22 la cour s'installe au
château d'amboise protégé par de solides
muraille
les conjurés souhaite éviter la violence
et veulent simplement remettre roy un
texte portant le titre les états de
france opprimés par la tyrannie de ce 2
ghz au roi leur souverain seigneur il
espère ainsi provoquer la réunion des
états généraux habilité à déclarer
illégitime le pouvoir déguise un édit
d'apaisement tente de calmer la
situation en offrant l'amnistié pour les
crimes d'hérésie
les premières arrestations ont lieu le
10 dans les bois aux abords d'amboise et
s'intensifie dans les jours qui suivent
les conjurés sont mal organisés et le 17
dans un dernier élan désespéré 200
hommes en armes tentent de forcer la
porte des bons hommes et tétanise le
couple royal et la cour
françois de guise sort finalement
renforcé de ce complot et fort de la
confiance que lui témoigne sa nièce
marie stuart l'entâme une répression
féroce
à la suite de ça il y aura quelque chose
comme 15 cents morts on imagine le
château d'amboise gorgé de cadavres
suspendus aux murailles larnaudie est en
coupe et en différents morceaux en cinq
ou six morceaux qu'on a essaimé dans
toute la ville d'amboise pour bien
montrer que qu'il a été vraiment fautif
d'avoir tenté cet enlèvement du roi et à
partir de ce moment là évidemment les
protestants qui ont été sévèrement
châtiés sévèrement punis vont se
transformer non plus en en partis
religieux mais en faction aux partis
politiques
une fois ce complot juif et l'église
paraissent tout puissant ils peuvent
même envisagé un temps de faire exécuter
le prince de condé ce qui n'arrivera pas
devant la violence de ces exécutions
sommaires sous les yeux horrifiés de la
cour
le poète agrippa d'aubigné dire un ils
ont décapité la france les bourreaux le
tempête pamphlétaire déferle alors
contre l'église et de nouveaux troubles
éclatent permettant à la reine mère
catherine de médicis de revenir sur la
scène politique afin de stabiliser
l'état
elle s'appuie sur son conseiller le
chancelier michel de l'hospital réputés
modérés humaniste influencé par les
idées d'erasme il est défavorable à une
division religieuse qui affaiblirait le
royaume il réprouve cependant l'usagé de
la force contre les protestants les 10
de romorantin en mai 15 cent soixante
marques pour un temps la fin des
persécutions
il accorde aux protestants la liberté de
conscience tout en leur refusant la
liberté de culte ne tolérance tacite
s'installe en attendant la réunion des
états généraux prévus pour décembre 15
160 mais bourbon sont traités de
rebelles quand l'information d'une
nouvelle conspiration parvient aux
oreilles du roi
catherine de médicis temps d'apaiser les
esprits en invitant antoine de bourbon
et le prince de condé à revenir à la
cour elle leur donne toutes les
garanties de sécurité et françois deux à
autre chose en tête
le prince de condé est arrêté et
condamné à mort mais les délibérations
sont suspendues car le roi est souffrant
le sort de condé est désormais lié à
celui du roi la santé de françois ii se
dégrade en décembre 15 160 l'église
sentent le pouvoir leur échapper
d'autant plus que la reine mary stuart
n'a pas donné d'héritier à la couronne
le 5 décembre
françois deux jeunes eurois à la santé
fragile rend l'âme
son frère charles neuf lui succèdent
sous la tutelle de la reine mère
catherine de médicis qui chasse les
guides du pouvoir et s'impose face à
antoine de bourbon
les cadres vont être très très vite
rabattu car cette situation qui est
celle de l'automne 459 est complètement
remodelé à la mort de françois ii dans
l'hiver qu'un 159 460 qui voit
effectivement la disgrâce sensible
déguise et le retour au pouvoir
autour du petit roi charles neuf qui la
lui est mineur effectivement il n'a
passé 13 ans révolus dont il est il est
en situation de minorité d'un groupe
constitué de la reine mère katherine de
nouveaux personnages compter des
personnages importants sous le règne de
théories de le maréchal de s'entendre et
le connétable de montmorency et antoine
de bourbon le le prince roi de navarre
au roi d'une partie de la navarre et qui
est un prince de la famille royale un
prince du sang c'est autour de ces gens
là que le pouvoir de nouveau s'articuler
[Musique]
après avoir perdu sa mère mary 2 ghz
quelques mois auparavant marie stuart se
trouve à accabler du deuil de son époux
françois 2 avec lequel elle a été élevée
et qu'elle aime sincèrement la petite
marie stuart et peuvent très rapidement
alors devenue veuve
que va-t-elle faire eh bien elle va
rester quelques temps en france
mais jusqu'à ce que catherine de médicis
le l'estimant qu'à moitié en se disant
elle n'a plus son utilité ici maintenant
donc on va se débarrasser d'elle elle va
le renvoyer en écosse la jeune veuve
porte le deuil durant 40 jours dans une
chambre noire comme le veut l'usagé
en juillet 15 à 161 marie stuart assiste
à une fête d'adieu donné en son honneur
à saint germain rennes de france
éphémère elle fait route vers calais
avant de renouer avec sa terre natale
brantôme écrira plus tard le déchirement
que vit la reine au moment de quitter la
france
les cov n'a pas échappé aux querelles
religieuses et à la diffusion des idées
protestante marie stuart qui a quitté
son royaume 13 ans auparavant se
retrouve dans une situation délicate
la régente mary 2 ghz avait eu bien du
mal à contenir les réformer réunis
derrière john knox est soutenu depuis le
début de l'année 1560 par la reine
d'angleterre elizabeth 1ère après la
mort de marie de guise le 10 juin 15 aux
160 le parlement écossais favorable au
protestantisme et souhaitons mettre un
terme à la guerre contre l'angleterre
signent le traité d'edimbourg le 6
juillet ce dernier met fin à l' auld
alliance entre l'écossé la france et
reconnaît elisabeth 1ère comme
souveraine légitime d'angleterre le
protestantisme devient alors la religion
officielle de l'ecosse l'autorité du
pape
n'étant plus reconnue
jugé humiliant par marie stuart la
souveraine refuse de ratifier ce traité
marc histoire trouve un royaume en proie
aux divisions religieuses et dans lequel
les protestants sont très puissants elle
ne prend pas la tête du parti catholique
comme l'aurait souhaité et ses partisans
et elle prêche même pour une sorte de
conciliation en prenant conseil auprès
de son demi-frère illégitime le compte
de mort et qui est l'un des chefs du
parti protestant alors que d'éventuels
prétendants prestigieux sont envisagées
mari tombe éperdument amoureuse de son
cousin henri stuart plus connu sous le
nom de l'ordre dans l'est et les pousses
de 29 juillet 15 165 cette union avec un
chef catholique au fût ce que le demi
frère de marie qui entre aussitôt en
rébellion lors d'armes les c'est un
aventurier un jaloux un intrigant marie
stuart et maltraité et humilié par sept
hommes dont l'un sociable appétit de
pouvoir va le conduire à conspirer
contre sa femme la reine decosse ne
parvient pas à réaliser l'unité
religieuse dans son royaume et sa
gouvernance est de plus en plus contesté
on l'a dit y réfléchir et à la merci de
ses pulsions le 19 juin 15 166 elle met
au monde un fils qui deviendra le roi
jacques 6 décosse et accédera aussi au
trône d'angleterre à la mort d'elizabeth
première sous le nom de jacques premier
comme elle est très malheureuse
marie stuart se console dans les bras
d'un amant mais c'est encore un
intrigant du shaq hepburn lord boswell
or ce fameux boss soit elle se verrait
bien porter la couronne décosse mais
voilà marie stuart est déjà marié alors
quelle est la solution
eh bien il envisage tout simplement
d'assassiner l'encombrant lord d'amener
ce dernier retrouvé étouffé une nuit de
février 1567
décosse est toujours en plein conflit
religieux et les combats font rage aux
quatre coins du royaume le 15 mai 15 à
167 c'est le coup de théâtre mary stuart
épouse lord boswell en troisièmes noces
ce mariage fait scandale et achève de
diviser les casses marie stuart et
discrédité est accusé de complicité dans
le meurtre de l'ordre dames les
protestants soutenu par la reine
d'angleterre se soulèvent boswell
abandonne marie stuart et s'enfuit du
royaume la reine decosse abdique alors
en faveur de son fils le 24 juillet 1567
et elle est emprisonnée à l'oc les
veines avant de s'enfuir en angleterre
où elisabeth 1ère va là gardée captive
[Musique]
mais
en france charles neuf second fils
d'henri 2 a succédé à son frère françois
2 sur le trône trop jeune pour régner
c'est la reine-mère catherine de médicis
qui assure la régence
dans un premier temps elle se montre
favorable au dialogue religieux et
envisage même une réconciliation
nationale
lors du colloque de poissy mais sept
confrontations théologiques est un échec
le destin de la lignée des guises suit
son cours il demeure puissant et vont
devenir le bras armé du camp catholique
menaçant l'autorité de catherine de
médicis
elle va commencer un jeu de bascule un
jeu qui va consister à essayer
d'équilibrer le rôle d'église en
s'alliant chaque fois que l'occasion se
présente avec des chefs du parti
protestant l'édit de tolérance de
janvier 15 162 légalise le culte public
des réformes et à condition qu'ils
s'exercent deux jours sans armes et à
l'extérieur des fils
cette reconnaissance de la foi
protestante par la monarchie provoque
l'indignation des ultra catholique
bien que protestants antoine de bourbon
choisi le camp des catholiques il
renforça s'il influence du duc de guise
le massacre des protestants de wassit
perpétré par le duc de guise en mars 15
162 met le feu aux poudres est plongé le
royaume dans les guerres de religion qui
vont dévasté la france pendant près de
36 ans jusqu'à la signature du fameux zi
de nantes par henri iv en 15 198 les
guerres de religions vont opposer un
parti protestant à la monarchie
massivement soutenu par les catholiques
ça c'est le cas de figure qui va durer
pendant disons les dix bonnes premières
années
la première guerre de religion voit
disparaître deux personnages essentiels
antoine de bourbon et le fervent
catholique du que françois de guise
dans les années 15 170 une nouvelle
génération entre dans le conflit le
nouveau duc de guise le catholique henry
poursuit la cause de son père le fils
d'emploi de bourbon henri de bourbon
jeune prince de navarre assume quant à
lui le rôle de chef des protestants
après la mort de son oncle le prince de
condé
charles neuf incline à une véritable
alliance militaire avec les protestants
le chef militaire des protestants et
temps l'amiral de coligny le chef
on peut dire du point de vue du du
prestige du point de vue de la relation
avec la famille royale c'est henri de
navarre
mais le chef militaire c'est l'amiral de
coligny alors catherine de médicis
depuis l'avènement de charles 9 jouent
ce jeu de bascule entre l'église et le
parti protestant lorsqu elles inclinent
du côté du parti protestant
elle met tout son poids dans la balance
pour conclure un mariage très politique
entre l'un des princes du parti
protestant qui s'appelle henri de
navarre le futur henri iv et l'une de
ses filles marguerite elle qu'on
appellera plus tard l'arête l'arago
alors le mariage d'henri de navarre et
de la petite margaux future reine margot
la fille de catherine de médicis est
prévue donc on a prévu de le célébrer à
paris a priori ça s'annonce bien puisque
tous les huis clos sont venus
accompagner leurs chefs
le jeune henry et on se prépare de
grandes réjouissances mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que catherine de médicis
l'on surnomme là serpente dans
l'histoire catherine de médicis à une
arrière pensée une arrière pensée dans
le crâne elle envisage manifestement de
venir à bout les protestants
[Musique]
et
les ghz favorise on favorise par house
et le climat qui en est la cause
mais un attentat contre colis et qui ne
permet pas de tuer collini mais lui
arrache un doigt le blesse à l'épaule et
c'est alors et coligny et les
protestants crient vengeance vengeance
et catherine de médicis ne sait plus
trop quel camp choisir
charles neuf lui est indigné par
l'attentât et va visiter coligny dans sa
maison lui dit justice sera faite et
c'est catherine de médicis se dit oui
mais nous sommes à paris
à paris ce sont les forces ultra
catholique qui l'emportent cd ghz
c'est pas très bon ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment puis je
voudrais pas non plus que coligny qui
est un personnage raid s'empare de la
direction des affaires par l'influencé
qu'il exerce auprès de charles neuf et
donc dans la nuit suivante
elle s'allie au guide pour expliquer à
charles neuf que les protestants ont
décidé d'attenter à sa vie de s'emparer
de lui mais dit un complot la colère
déclenché chez charles neuf une crise de
folie et le roi déclare tu es l'amiral
meet you lie tous pour qu'il n'en reste
pas un pour me le reprocher
les cloches du beffroi de l'église saint
germain l'auxerrois sont alors le signal
du massacre de la saint barthélémy qui
déferle sur paris dans la nuit du 23 au
24 août 15 162
la cour d'espagne et la cour de rome les
deux grandes courbes catholique celle
qui pèse le plus lourd sans doute à ce
moment là le pape d'un côté et le roi
d'espagne l'on se réjouisse absolument
de cette opération dont il faut bien
voir qu'elle est conçue par eux et en
partie parce qu'ils l'ont mise en oeuvre
comme une purification du royaume de
france n'a royaume qui est pollué par
une souillure religieuse fondamentale
[Musique]
craignant les coups de forces
catholiques à l'image du massacre de la
saint barthélémy qui a tétanisé les
protestants de toute l'europe et au
regard des nombreux complots fomentés
contre la souveraine anglaise
elisabeth 1ère envisage de se
débarrasser de marie stuart quand la
reine déchue après sa condamnation à
mort elle écrite à henri iii le nouveau
roi de france qui fut autrefois son beau
frère
mais à rien ne vient contrarier le cours
de son destin tragique qui prend fin le
8 février 15 187 et mary stuart va être
exécuté mais dans des conditions non cet
abominable parce que d'abord on
l'habille d'une robe rouge que l'on
destinait généralement aux femmes de
mauvaise vie
ensuite plutôt que de lui trancher le
col avec le glaive comme on aurait pu le
faire parce que c'était une une femme de
la famille royale
eh bien on le fait à la hache tout
simplement le bourreau est parfaitement
ivre mort ce jour-là il paraît qu'il a
dû frapper à trois reprises avant de
décoller la tête complètement du corps
de la petite marie stuart est ravi de
son le son coût de ces trois coups si je
puis dire
le bourreau s'empare de la tête mais il
lui reste la perruque dans la main car
elle avait perdu tous ses cheveux et
elle portait une perruque une mort
absolument abominable pour une petite
reine de france 2 quelques mois
la fin tragique de marie stuart n'a
cessé d'inspirer les auteurs digne
représentante des très catholiques
disent la figure romanesque de marie
stuart se déploie à travers la légende
de l'intrigante et de la reine martyrs
victimes du protestantisme
quand elle meurt sous la lame du
bourreau en 15 187 elle ne se doute pas
qu'elle est à l'origine de la lignée qui
par son fils jacques régnera enfin après
la mort de son implacable rival
elisabeth sur l'angleterre tant convoité